ABCs of AI K is for K means plus plus K
means plus plus is an enhanced
initialization technique for the k-means
clustering algorithm it strategically
selects initial centroids centers of
each cluster Based on data point
distances that leads to faster Superior
clustering outcomes which means better
analysis of data sets resource
optimization and more agile decision
making with bigquery ML and Google Cloud
you can choose to use k-means plus as
the initialization method for your
clusters make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss an update and let us know
what other AI topics do you want to know
more about on the next episode of